we'll labor ever again regain economic
credibility while Chris Leslie is
Labor's shadow chief secretary to the
Treasury a job he's done since October
2013 he joins me now very good morning
to you hello mr. Leslie and of course
well then you'll that you'll be the
senior Treasury spokesman with with Ed
Balls gone easy that's a big loss to
your party isn't of course it is and as
is Douglas Alexander and of course ed
Miliband as well and I think you know
they've served the party incredibly well
over recent years and it is a blow to to
lose those big individuals who've done
such you know important things for the
party
so I mean does that make you the Shadow
Chancellor or I suppose there's no one
in charge exits to make those decisions
but you know we've got to then put these
economic questions to you was at the
core of your campaign and that's related
to what Lord Mandelson has just been
saying he says the impression you gave
was that you hated the rich you wanted
to tax their salaries tax their houses
tax their pensions and they felt they
were not included in the big where was
it a big labor tent well look I mean it
has been a very bruising 48 hours for us
in the Labor Party and you're right to
say that we need to focus on the reasons
why we lost I think that there were a
lot of people who wanted to support the
Labour Party but that when it came to
that ballot box and the ballot paper
they just felt that they couldn't and
we've got to understand why they were
hesitant why they were fearful now I
think there were a number of factors
wasn't that aspirational message there
that if you get rich we don't really
stand for you I think there was it was
too easy for the Conservatives to pedal
the miss perception that somehow we want
anti-business and somehow we were not
standing up for that centigram for that
middle income group of people in this
country who I think are important in the
entrepreneurial way of generating wealth
welcome Aaron was talking about people
at the very top well look I mean we want
a fairer society and we want social
justice the Labour Party will always
want that but we've got to make sure
that we get that trust back on the
economy and I'm actually quite focused
you know for this particular period on
the fact that the Chancellor the Prime
Minister now that they have this
majority they're not going to wait
around for the Labour Party they're
going to be getting on with their agenda
and we know
oh that there are some massive massive
cuts to come to public services Social
Security they haven't really explained
where from and of course their manifesto
they were elected on was predicated very
much on unfunded commitments now put
those two things together you've got an
enormous black hole and I'm not going to
let George Osborne or David Cameron get
away without explaining who is going to
be paying the price for that so where
would you like to see when Labour does
get its act together campaigning from
what part of the political spectrum Lord
Mandelson laying out his stall his
vision very clearly Tony Blair writing
today in the paper saying you cannot
abandon the center ground there are
others saying well no no the example we
have to take comes from Scotland
the SNP stood to the left of us on those
social and economic questions that's
what we need to do what's your view well
there is a job to rebuild in Scotland
but I'm and I've been saying this
already there is a moment from from
almost the 28th let me explain I think
in England and Wales as I was saying
there were a lot of people wanting to
support labour you could even see it in
those now slightly discredited opinion
polls that there were you know wanting
to be with us but those fears and
anxieties they were they are difficult
to confront but we have to confront them
why did people pause why were they
hesitant some of that I think was partly
the question about could they trust us
on the economy I think the Conservatives
were very successful in whipping up that
fear that somehow Nicola Sturgeon and
the Labour Party were would would create
that greater risk that also made people
hesitate but look we've got to get this
right we've got to focus on our new
vision for the future and an understand
and analyze what happened but in the
interim period we've also got to make
sure that we hold those torez now but
now's the time it's less isn't it son
level with the public we're not in a
general election campaign we won't be
for nearly another five years and you
make it sound as if people just
misinterpreted the policies you had
going into that general election do you
feel they were just the wrong policies
well I think there is certainly a lot of
reviewing we have to do if the whole of
are they the right policies with the
wrong interpretation or just the right
I am not the sort of character that goes
back and trashes what we've just been
arguing or our legacy in the past I am a
proud member of a team in the Labour
Party we all take a collective
responsibility for this but of course
it's the perceptions of the public we've
got to listen to if we interpretation we
certainly know along the line what we
like we feel alone but there's a very
great question from your point of view
would you keep the mansion tax would you
keep the increase in the top rate of tax
would you keep the raids on big pension
funds
well we've we've judged the election
those policies did not succeed they've
all got a didn't they they where they
like to be refused or the wrong party
I think look I'm not going to stand
today 48 hours after arguing but I still
see sometimes some things they were the
wrong point I agreed with the platform
that we put out but the public things
and therefore for the power it's the
best thing to do no the public I think
of course correct in their judgment but
we have to listen to what they were
saying and in particular I want to
listen to those views in England and
Wales in particular because they were
hesitant about us on that and that's why
I think we've got to make sure we have a
broad appeal draw people together in the
party but listen to those you know
things about wealth creation and not
just about wealth distribution important
of course all riders but this there is a
fundamental question it's not about
policy and it's again flowing from Lord
Mandelson throne from Tony Blair today
was the big error made long before the
campaign started when Ed Miliband said
are not Tony Blair you jumped that pass
you lost that that winning record you
denied all the successes of those Blair
and brown years no and I understand the
arguments that are being made but look
this can't be about going back and
fighting those old battles of 7 or 12
councils I mean there were six seats
there were election victories say well I
wasn't I was in either injuries like the
red ones and I'm very proud of being a
minister in previous Labour government's
but I think now we need to face the
future the longer-term question is how
we of course create that because Mr
Miliband Mr Miliband about the energy
what is ground there's an immediate task
away what I'm very concerned about that
it is basically George Osborne and David
Cameron they will be rushing to get
their agenda through the Conservative
Party I suspect is going to
right meant on the number of different
ways particularly on Europe but when it
comes to the economy and it comes to
public services we've got reform those
public services but we've also got to
make sure we pinned them down on where
those cuts are going to fall and who is
going to be you know that being that is
our immediate job but you know your
problem is who's going to be making
those arguments in Parliament who have
got their act together it's Alex Salmond
and cohort of SNP MPs and I think we we
should have been very clear from earlier
on that we have no truck with them I
mean we we absolutely spelled out that
we wouldn't do deals with them and I
think that was the right thing to do but
we allowed the Conservative Party to
peddle that myth and of course that that
percolated into people's anxieties about
us and that in many ways is part of the
reason I think we we have seen a
conservative majority good to see mr.
Lessing thank you very much indeed Chris
Leslie there